le conseil départemental de la réunion
vous présente lien social le conseil
départemental aux côtés des réunionnais
la féerie arrive enfin avec la quatrième
édition de au bonheur des enfants ou le
conseil départemental met tout en oeuvre
pour que tous les enfants réunionnais
est taxé à la magie de noël
tout est fait pour que leurs yeux
brillent avec une programmation riche et
innovante
musique danse jeux ballon activités
culturelles ferme géante et tant
d'activités festives et culturelles
cet événement est une merveilleuse
vitrine des savoir-faire des services du
conseil départemental
quel est le programme cette année deux
au bonheur des enfants
quelles sont les dates de cette
opération de noël on en parle tout de
suite dans lien social
c'est noël à partir du 15 décembre à 18
heures et jusqu'au 23 décembre de 10h à
20h avec des nocturnes jusqu'à 22h le
jardin de l'état se met au rythme des
enfants pour cette magnifique
manifestation au bonheur des enfants
le conseil départemental offre 9 jouent
aux familles réunionnaises pour que la
joie soit dans le coeur des enfants
vous aurez le bonheur de découvrir une
ferme géante installée sur le parking
poivre les enfants pourront nourrir les
animaux mais également une ruche un
espace potager des plantations des
structures gonflables des jeux une
patinoire et manèges pour ravir petits
et grands
les plus téméraires pourront participer
à l'activité grimpe aux arbres ou
découvrir la mini fort est endémique des
animations diverses pour que chacun soit
le plus créatif possible les espaces de
lecture de contes la fabrication de ses
propres objets avec l'atelier de bois de
goyavier des espaces culturels des
ateliers autour du chocolat du coloriage
du découpage et cette année un mini
festival du film sur le thème de
l'enfant et la nature des plateaux
musicaux ou de danse avec de jeunes
artistes seront de la fête
tous les soirs un spectacle son et
lumière absolument magique new gravity
un groupe d'acrobaties urbaines seront
présents le 20 décembre omnium erviti
c'est une association qui réunit donc
des pratiquants de parcours free running
three kings et diverses disciplines
acrobatiques
ça fait presque quatre ans que
l'association a été fondée à l'origine
de cette association il ya un groupe
donc on vient d'un peu partout sur l'île
principalement des membres de saint
denis
notre principal objectif c'est de faire
connaître la discipline à la réunion et
puis aussi d'enlever les préjugés en
quelque sorte qu'il ya sur notre sport
qui n'est pas connu et pas reconnu donc
on essaie vraiment de montrer aux gens
que dans ce sport il peut y avoir de
vraies valeurs qu'il ya beaucoup
d'entraînement que c'est un sport
difficile autant moralement que
physiquement et surtout que voilà on
n'est pas des délinquants
le parcours s'est donc
ou on peut aussi l'appeler art du
déplacement le but c'est réellement de
se mouvoir dans un environnement urbain
en passant sur des obstacles après nous
on évolue devant le théâtre de champ
fleuri régulièrement où on donne aussi
des cours pour les jeunes le mercredi le
samedi de 14 heures à 17 heures donc ça
fait quatre ans qu'on est suivi par le
théâtre de champ fleuri et on a fait de
nombreuses délocalisations et de tourner
sur des scènes en extérieur et c'est à
ce titre justement que
on a une rotation le 20 décembre dans le
cadre du festival au bonheur des enfants
au jardin et à devant le musée
il
au bonheur des enfants du 15 dès demain
au 23 décembre vraiment le bonheur avec
des spectacles une ferme géante des vols
de rapaces une superbe décoration pour
émerveiller les adultes comme les tout
petits sur le thème des quatre saisons
et puis bien évidemment tous les jeux
tous le savoir faire des agents du
conseil départemental qui depuis quatre
ans met à disposition de tous et pour le
bonheur de tous leur savoir faire et
leur savoir être pour leur dire merci et
venez nombreux ça sera géant au bonheur
des enfants
c'est ça et c'est plus que ça la magie
de noël sans oublier les acteurs
culturels et économiques réunionnais des
jeux éducatifs en relation avec
l'environnement pour créer demain c'est
avant tout les yeux qui pétillent
les a et les eaux devant les spectacles
les rires les champs bref une grande et
belle fête
réalisé pour que tous les enfants
réunionnais malgré les difficultés
puissent avoir droit à la féerie de noël
au bonheur des enfants
c'est du 15 décembre 18 heures jusqu'au
23 décembre
ouverture tous les jours à 10h soyez au
rendez vous également pour les nocturnes
les 15 18 19 et 22 décembre jusqu'à 22
heures
et pour le 20 décembre rendez vous
autour d'une grande fête de 20 heures à
minuit
tout le programme sur www.cc no 7 4
point fr joyeuses fêtes à tous le
conseil départemental de la réunion vous
a présenté lien social
le conseil départemental aux côtés des
réunionnais